it's
been 30 years and it must
feel it it must feel good that this work
stands the test of time well it does
feel good we'll come back in the 50y
year anniversary and see what kind
of what we have to offer yeah and uh
it's great that people are are
interested and that we have the
opportunity to do this and to to like
add it's there's vinyl and there's live
shows so you can you won't be tracked or
have a cookie put on your Consciousness
and you can just put the the tone arm
down on a piece of vinyl and listen to
Nirvana live in Rome or Los Angeles or
Seattle and you can be it'll it can
capture imagination you're invited to
come to come inside that world and
experience that show so you know I'm
just happy to to have the opportunity
and you said that there's no you don't
play play Nirvana at home no mean is
this going to be an exception do you
think no I mean the cool thing about
being a musician for a long time making
a bunch of Records is that you
eventually start measuring your life not
in like increments of time or whatever
it's
like albums that you've made so if you
ask me about a particular record a
scream record or a Foo Fighters record
or whatever I'll immediately know what
year it was made and and I remember
almost everything about where I was and
who I was at that time so when I think
like 30 years ago what the
what's that even mean 30 years but if
you say 1993 I everything comes back and
then when you listen to it to me it's
almost like these um they're sort of
like Sonic snapshots like in a photo
album or something and
um so when I when I hear the music it
brings back a lot of of personal Vivid
memories of just stupid like I
remember that jacket that I had or that
stupid hat I bought in North Carolina or
the sock full of mashed potatoes that
Steve put in my suit
snuck I felt bad when that got ripped
off I know I was so sad but things like
that but then also um you know again you
know I I refer to my children a lot
because they're they're uh discovering
music in the same way that well
differently than we did then but sort of
emotionally in the same way that we did
at their age and
um and you know to see their reaction to
this music Now is really cool
actually we did this one we did this uh
this uh charity benefit thing once that
uh art of alium thing that we did a long
time ago and we got asked to play this
thing in Los Angeles or they asked the
Foo Fighters to play but we couldn't
make it and and then the person who was
putting on the show said well why don't
you just play acoustic I'm like man
I don't want to do that so I thought you
know what maybe I'll call Chris and Pat
and see if maybe Joan Jed will come up
and we can do some neurana songs or
maybe someone else is there whatever so
um we were thinking about people to sing
and then I don't know who brought it up
but some maybe it was you that said does
violet want to sing a song or maybe it
was Pat my daughter Violet and um I saw
this did you see it there was yeah there
was footage of it yeah and so I I was
like well I'll ask her and I said hey VI
um she's an incredible singer I'm like
and she really likes Nirvana at the time
I think she was maybe
14 probably 14 14-year-old
girl um I said you want to sing an
Nirvana song she's like yeah
absolutely and I said um which one of
all of them not just this record of all
of them and she picks Heart Shaped Box
mhm and my first reaction
was what have I done to my kid to
them up so
bad that this is that this is the song
they want to sing but um but seriously I
was I was very uh proud yeah and what I
realized is kids these days there's like
this window in between the ages of like
maybe 10 and 13 or 11 and 14 or
something like that where almost every
kid goes through a Nirvana phase and
it's for a reason and I think it has
less to do with the
sound um I think it has more to do with
what it means because I think it means
the same thing today to those kids as it
did when we released it so that to me is
the coolest thing and selling a lot of
t-shirts
yeah